so she said okay look i'll take you on
if you bring if you come if you sign
with us commercially
and i said okay great and out the gate i
started booking commercials for them
they were like it worked out i was like
well let's talk about these uh
theatrical auditions though
and then within two months of being with
this agency i was on new girl
and that's such a story that you've
probably told a million times but the
first thing i thought of was like i
wonder if he ever thanked damon wayans
jr for not coming back to the show i
wonder if he actually said thank you
because man my took off
all the time
all of you know him
yeah damon's the homie like we yeah we
always trying to develop together and uh
he's uh
he's the the best like he is
and he was so he was on the show he was
the pilot but he had a conflict with
another show that he was doing called
happy endings and so he couldn't do it
so instead of writing the character off
instead of like replacing the character
they just wrote him off and then just
hired you for the second episode
right
in a nutshell that's what happened it's
a lot longer than that but pretty much
that's how it went down um prior to it i
want to say
i don't know if he auditioned or didn't
but prior to it i got an offer to play
that role
of coach but i had a prior engagement i
had a prior obligation to cbs
and i'm talking within hours we were
trying to get them to make an offer for
me for new girl after i had auditioned a
couple times
and it was like why would we make him an
offer he's got a test like everybody
else and and my agents were saying well
because cbs is making him an offer from
another show
and they were like impossible like
nobody again he's done a few commercials
but like you know and so cbs was i was
literally at the test for new girl and
before you signed that contract
i got a call from my agent saying don't
sign the contract we got an offer cbs
i was like oh it was this pilot called
the assistants it was uh with t.j miller
and heather locklear david henry sarah
wright
um jason jones it was a great great show
the pilot was really funny the cast was
amazing um it just didn't go
and in that
time damon had signed up to do new girl
not knowing if he could actually
officially do it because he did he said
he had happy endings right so everything
just started working out him leaving
me having me come back in for a new
character that i auditioned 15 times for
you auditioned 15 times for for your
character yes well 11 for my character
11 for my character i want to say and
then the other times for coach
11 times what do they need to see
that they won't see if they rewound the
tape on the first one
i don't know
were you doing anything different were
you doing anything different
they would change the material up a
little bit here and there but i was like
just imagine that i said it
like how i said the other joke
but at one point i started losing hope i
was like i don't think i wanna
i remember the last part the last leg of
this audition i tested maybe three or
four times i want to say
and i remember the last
audition i had i thought i booked it
like jake johnson
emailed me it was like
he was like dude i think you got it
i was like oh my god that's awesome then
it gives me a call right back
oh so there's this kid
there's justin heyers and justin heyers
he's on macgyver right now
is a stud
so when they told me justin was reading
i was like
damn it
i saw this for nothing i was like here
comes justin's
punk ass gonna take my job
and luckily i i booked it um
but yeah